early on you played a lot of tomboys and
that kind of character and then you got
a part in a movie called am I getting
this right Willie
what is it well it was called Willy
Mille well first it was called I was a
teenage boy then it was Willie Mille
than it was something special and I play
a girl whose greatest deepest darkest
wish is to be a boy so Seth Green sells
me a crystal that I throw at the moon on
the night of an eclipse and I wake up
the next day and I have a penis was this
movie supposed to be for kids well guess
what we have the trailer let's take a
look truly a miracle has happened to
Milly and now the fun begins last night
she was a girl this morning she's a
movies unlike anything you've seen
before Stephanie can you do things with
it I don't know I won't government marry
one
there's never been a change of equipment
comedy like willy nilly there's never
been a change of equipment comedy yeah
John comedies look at your voice hasn't
she I didn't feel comfortable like that
like if I was wearing a dress right now
could I sit like this yes you could we
encourage that here
you